this week for as a birthday present for
me we found the worst criminal in the
world uh Brian Walsh I've been following
this story I think this is what a gift
to Comedy this guy is
this guy uh allegedly killed his wife we
don't know but they did find I'm not
making this part up
we're going to get to the part I'm
making up but it's not this part
they found his Google searches this guy
apparently is so stupid he does not
understand that we can all see what you
we could see anything nowadays anything
you write anywhere okay just if you
think it we probably know it but
certainly Google these are the real
Google searches of Mr Brian Walsh whose
wife is missing how long before a body
starts to smell
he Googled 10 ways to dispose of a body
if you really need to
how long for someone to be missing to
inherit
[Applause]
how to clean blood from a wooden floor
is it better to throw crime scene
clothes away or wash them
we found out some other people who have
Google searches now this is the part I'm
making up uh would you like to see some
of those because you know a lot of
people don't get this about Google
searches like Gavin Newsom Google
statistically how many 80 year old
presidents make it through their first
term
all right
see that's very
uh Kanye Googled Christian dentist in my
area
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Matt Gates Chuck E cheese is near me
suspicious
Kylie Jenner Mother's Day gifts for dad
[Applause]
wines that go with Chinese oh
come on
Meghan Markle Googled is the race card
an actual card
[Applause]
um
Johnny Depp Google do courts check
what's in your thermos
[Applause]
and 10 foods that will help you poop oh
well that's very
nice
and Kevin McCarthy Googled what does
Speaker of the House do